the US is formally telling the United
Nations that it has started the process
of pulling out of the Paris climate
agreement nearly 200 nations signed the
landmark deal to cut greenhouse gas
emissions the u.s. is the only country
to withdraw in the meantime India which
remains in the agreement is dealing with
the worst pollution crisis in its
capital in three years
Elizabeth Palmer's following India's
struggle with pollution and she shows us
how bad the air is affecting 29 million
people in New Delhi this is world class
smog the Indian government has closed
schools introduce measures to cut
traffic by half and told citizens to
stay indoors it's actually scary you
can't see things in front of you autumn
fills New Delhi's air with tons of Filth
smoke from burning crops on top of
construction dust and car exhaust
we have no non smoker in India everybody
living in India is a smoker chest
surgeon dr. Arvind Kumar says just
breathing in Delhi is equivalent to
smoking 25 cigarettes a day with
catastrophic fallout we saw it for
ourselves earlier this year of the
emergency ward of Delhi's National
Institute for TB and respiratory disease
800 people line up every single day with
lung problems tackling a crisis this
serious says activist anumita Chaudhary
needs radical thinking so where do you
start it has to be multi sector across
all sectors of pollution vehicles
industries power plant waste burning
construction activities for long
suffering residents of this mega city
action can't come fast enough because
the wait is literally killing them for
CBS this morning
I'm Elizabeth Palmer people are day in
that hospital that's an extraordinary
really killing them and you don't see
that - you can see it yeah the the
climate Accords the Paris agreement
there that's one of the many things that
are at stake in the 2020 elections